[Musique]
brunoh bonjour bonjour à tous
merci aux orateurs qui m'entourent et
que je vais présenter à l'issue de mes
propos introductif un asseyez vous je
vous en prie je suis très heureuse
d'être parmi vous pour animer ce
troisième atelier qui clôturera cette
matinée avant la pause déjeuner d'autant
plus satisfaite que moi même j'ai été
rdj et qu'en 2004 j'avais eu l'occasion
d'accueillir en haute savoie une
université d'été qui avait évidemment
marqué notre famille politique c'était
l'ump à l'époque cher christian et donc
je suis très heureuse évidemment d'être
parmi vous ce matin pour ses différents
débats qui montrait bien que notre
famille politique elle travaille sur le
fond pour préparer l'avenir et préparer
l'alternance
alors le sujet qui nous réunit ce matin
évidemment il est très important pour
notre famille politique c'est un sujet
qui est avant tout d'actualité
cette question du délitement de
l'autorité on peut la décliner à tous
niveaux dans l'éducation nationale au
niveau des élus et je crois qu'on a pu
observer un certain nombre d'anecdotes
d'événements au cours desquelles eh bien
on a des élus qui ont été menacés ce qui
est une première on avait rarement vu et
bien ce genre d'agression que ce soit à
leur permanence mais que ce soit aussi à
leur domicile ou dans l'exercice de
leurs fonctions et je tient évidemment à
les dénoncer
mais aussi évidemment et bien cette
question de l'autorité de l'état qui
aujourd'hui plus que jamais a été remise
en cause par est bien certain nombre de
faits divers que et dont vous avez
entendu parler tout au cours de l'été et
qui ont tendance malheureusement à
s'accroître alors cédé ces dernières
semaines évidemment ils ont été marqués
par une violence très important dans
notre pays
je pense aux chauffeurs de bus qui a été
tué aux règlements de compte qui s'est
tenue à dijon alarme de guerre aux
policiers et gendarmes qui ont été tués
également au vandalisme sur les champs
elysées et donc ces violences et ne sont
inédites ni localiser et elles
traduisent et bien un ans sauvagement de
notre société
l'utilisation de ce terme est d'ailleurs
controversés
entre certains ministres vous l'avez vu
du gouvernement actuel puisqu'ils n'ont
pas du tout la même exception de ce
terme est d'ailleurs le garde des sceaux
eric dupond moretti a expliqué cette
semaine que le sentiment d'insécurité
c'est de l'ordre du fantasme
la france n'est pas un coupe gorge et
pourtant la france enregistre un record
des coups et blessures volontaires
c'était à peu près cinq cent soixante
par jour sous le quinquennat sarkozy
il y en a 200 plus par jour aujourd'hui
nous sommes le deuxième pays européens
sur 27 par rapport au nombre
d'agressions les violences à l'endroit
des forces de l'ordre c'est environ 100
actes par jour nous notons également
évidemment un manque de places de place
dans les prisons nous n'avons cessé de
le dénoncer
emmanuel macron s'était engagé à la
construction de 15000 places
finalement il est revenu et bien sûr sur
cet objectif à 7000 et aujourd'hui la
chancellerie annonce un chiffre de 4500
sachant que suite au confinement
il y a à peu près 13 mille détenus qui
sont sortis des prisons c'est quasiment
et bien un cinquième des détenus qui ont
été libérés plus évidemment lieu
l'inexécution des peines et toutes les
ce qui ne se passe pas en matière de
justice donc cette situation évidemment
est pour le moins inquiétante au regard
de un certain nombre d'indicateurs
objectifs et cette dégradation elle joue
un rôle évidemment dans notre démocratie
on a pu noter une hausse de l'abstention
lors des dernières élections quelles
qu'elles soient y compris des élections
municipales alors que vous savez qu'en
principe c'est l'élection qui mobilise
le plus
alors certes nous étions dans un
contexte de co vide mais c'est un
niigata un indicateur important qui
témoigne bien d'une défiance à l'endroit
de notre démocratie à l'endroit des
politiques est aussi un échec de la
politique d' emmanuel macron avant de
présenter les trois intervenants je
voulais vous citer une anecdote locale
qui concerne mon département ma
circonscription qui concerne les gens du
voyage et qui je crois est assez
symptomatique
vous avez évidemment des communautés de
gens du voyage qui ont fait ce choix et
qui ont des airs des aires d'accueil
qui ont été organisées évidemment par
les collectivités mais parfois eh bien
ils s'installent de façon illicite sur
des terrains privés ou publics
nous avons eu ce cas en haute savoie et
ces personnes ont été mises en demeure
de quitter les lieux et ont fait un
recours finalement elles sont parties et
elles ont laissé un terrain dans un état
lamentable
avec évidemment des raccordements à
l'eau et à l'électricité qui étaient
illégaux ils ont laissé deux piscines
hors sol et ils ont aussi lisse et
laisser des déchets un amas de déchets
puisqu'il fait ils font des petits
travaux qui sont pas déclarés et
notamment et bien des objets lourds et
de l'amiante coût pour la collectivité
50000 euros
et quand nos concitoyens voient ça
évidemment ils sont écoeurés et il
constate l'impuissance de l'état parce
que eux ils vous disent eh bien nous les
braves gens on paye nos contravention on
se prend une amende de 150 euros ou 165
euros lorsqu'on ne porte pas le masque
et ces gens là on leur dit rien et il y
a un sentiment d'impunité dans notre
pays qui accentue évidemment ce
délitement
voilà quelques éléments de cadrage et
d'introduction que je voulais avoir pour
commencer avant et bien de vous
présenter les trois intervenants qui
m'entourent et qui vont et bien j'irai
les plus au fond de ce sujet et de cet
enjeu important
alors je vais commencer dans l'ordre
inverse de leur prise de parole en
présentant d'abord bruno retailleau que
vous connaissez évidemment toutes et
tous qui est sénateur de la vendée mais
surtout président du groupe l air au
sénat je le remercie d'être là
aujourd'hui parce qu'il est en campagne
en ce moment c'est vrai qu'il ya des
échéances pour nos sénateurs je salue
évidemment gérard larcher également le
27 septembre prochain il ya quasiment
quasiment la moitié des sénateurs qui
sont renouvelables
si l'on ne compte pas les représentants
de des français de l'étranger
donc merci de ta présence tu es un
spécialiste de ces sujets régaliens et
tu portes
notre voie aux efforts dans les médias
je remercie également jean daniel lévy
depuis près de 20 ans
vous êtes un expert en matière de
sondages et vous présidez évidemment
l'institut harris interactive et vous
intervenez évidemment sur ces sujets
dans les médias en tant qu'analyste des
opinions et donc vous intervenez
également comme éditorialiste sur lcp
donc on vous laissera la parole
évidemment pour analyser un certain
nombre d' enquête en lien avec ce sujet
et pour commencer et bien nous allons
donner la parole à marie glinel qui est
doctorante en droit public qui nous
vient de haute garonne qui est élu
également au cneser et qui a donc
travaillé hier sur cet atelier avec
gilles platret qui en était je crois à
l'animateur et donc vous allez
aujourd'hui nous faire la restitution de
ce qui s'est dit formulé un certain
nombre de propositions
je laisserai ensuite évidemment la
parole à nos deux autres orateurs et
puis nous pourrons comme cela a été fait
précédemment avoir un échange et un
débat avec la salle
merci marie de votre présence merci
madame être désolé d'avoir crié merci
mesdames et député donc demain tre dirai
merci donc aux organisateurs de cet
événement de donner la parole aux jeunes
et merci surtout aux jeunes d'être là si
présent pour nous faire vraiment croire
en la droite
ça fait plaisir donc j'ai eu la lourde
de tâche donc de rapporter sur le sujet
de l'autorité et comme je disais hier
pour ceux qui étaient là c'est d'autant
plus difficile que c'est un sujet sur
lequel finalement notre parti a une
parole déjà très rodé et je suis
d'ailleurs très émue et d'intervenir à
côté de monsieur retailleau qui est
lui-même à une pauline paroles très très
rôdée sur ce sujet c'est la raison pour
laquelle je vous ferai part de mon
sentiment donc par rapport à cette table
ronde d'hier alors comme ici nous sommes
tous de droite n'avons pas peur de le
dire nous aimons l'ordre nous aimons
l'autorité nous aimons finalement cette
verticalité et en fait non hier nous
avons vu que cela faisait consensus
auprès de chacun chacune des personnes
finalement qui est intervenue que ce
soit à la table-ronde ou bien chez les
jeunes cette question là ne fait pas
débat l'autorité finalement
est acceptée nous aimons ça est en fait
travaillé sur cette table ronde m'a
permis de manière assez intéressante de
m'interroger sur cette évidence est si
évident que ça des mails autorités alors
que je me suis jamais posé la question
finalement aurions nous besoin
finalement d'autorité dans un état
tranquille dans un état sans délinquance
et donc c'est à partir de ce cas fictif
ce cas limites qu'il aurait été
intéressant de travailler finalement
redéfinir les fondations finalement au
cette autorité alors c'est la raison
pour laquelle juste deux petits points
seront intéressants donc un point de
définition et un point de situation de
l'autorité alors au niveau de la
définition l'autorité à mon sens c'est
quelque chose qui parle à la raison ça
ne parle pas à la peur ça ne parle pas
aux angoisses sa part là la raison et
c'est la raison pour laquelle il faudra
distinguer deux types d'autorité une
autorité plutôt positive une autorité
valeur c'est l'autorité qui impulsent
quelque chose un mouvement qui est un
peu plus finalement le respect donc là
c'est plutôt la auctoritas chez les
romains et de l'autre côté l'autorité
plutôt attitude plutôt négative
c'est-à-dire l'autorité qu'il impose la
contrainte la force
cette autorité négatif j'ai fait preuve
d'autoritarisme et donc la potasse est
donc ce à partir de cette distinction
finalement qu'il aurait été intéressant
de d'étudier la chose puisque je me
rends compte que hier on a surtout parlé
de la potasse mais pas de là auctoritas
et c'est ça qui finalement peut-être
fait défaut d'en bas dans les
discussions que nous avons alors c'est
la raison pour laquelle sur le plan de
la situation ne pouvons interrogé donc
la perception de l'autorité par le
peuple qui depuis mai 68 j'imagine
qu'ici tout le monde sera d'accord pour
dire que l'autorité a pris un tournant
très négatif
nous sommes passés d'une conception de
la domination enfin d'une conception de
la légitimité charismatique ou le
l'autorité finalement c'est cette cette
puissance c'est le respect de ce chef
sacré qui s'imposent et nous sommes
passés après mai 68 donc à une
conception de la de l'autorité plutôt
finalement légal rationnels comme dirait
un max de bach ou finalement tout
fonctionne sur le plan de
l'horizontalité et c'est ça qui
distingue la droite et la gauche
fondamentalement c'est cette
horizontalité versus cette verticalité
nous croyons encore la verticalité
quand la gauche nous impose
horizontalité et c'est ce qui fait que
finalement nous aurons à gauche cet élan
finalement chacun voudra prendre la
place du chef puisque l'autorité n'est
plus le chef n'est plus autorisé enfin
en tout cas pour la gauche qui promeut
ce ce discours alors nous avons vu un
consensus indéniable sur cette question
hier qui n'a peut-être pas été développé
dans ces termes un peu conceptuel mais
qui finalement
était là et donc le lien entre
l'autorité la démocratie qui a fait
défaut hier mais je le comprends tout à
fait c'est justement cette perte de
l'autorité de l'élu nous avons un
divorce aujourd'hui dans la démocratie
que dans laquelle nous sommes
un divorce entre la liberté des anciens
et des modernes un divorce entre cet
état qui garantit les libertés qui
garantit l'expression des libertés cette
liberté des modernes mais qui par
conséquent aussi est plus faible sur le
gouvernement de tous en commun la
liberté des anciens et donc ça à partir
de revendications sociales que nous
avons pu dont nous avons pu percevoir
finalement les les soubresauts de ces
dernières années enfin ces derniers mois
sous le le début du quinquennat macron
enfin du président macron pardonner mans
que nous nous rendrons compte qu'en fait
le peuple a besoin finalement de
remettre la démocratie au sens de tous
ses deux principales revendications sont
être à la fois la source de la décision
mais également la finalité de la
décision publique ce n'est ni plus ni
moins que la définition de la démocratie
tout le monde en conviendra
et donc quelques petites pistes de
réflexion ont été abordés hier si nous
les mettons en oeuvre déjà réaffirmé
l'autorité comme valeur nous voulons une
autorité positive une autorité qui
impose qu'ils impulsent payne autorités
violente nécessairement puisque
finalement c'est ça c'est l'autorité de
l'état que nous voulons que nous voulons
incarner à droite et c'est ce qui nous
distingue aura aussi assez
essentiellement de la reine et du r n
qui dans les paroles et les actes
puisque certains sont au pouvoir et
d'autres non nous démontre en fait
qu'ils sont sur cette conception très
négatif de l'autorité qui font preuve
d'autoritarisme
alors que nous voulons nous revenir à un
débat plus positif plus apaisé et c'est
là dessus que nous avons quelque chose à
faire pour proposer un discours beaucoup
plus audible auprès des français
notamment visage et de l'autorité est
donc proposé cette autorité positive
valeur ensuite réaffirmé la verticalité
du pouvoir ça nous étions tous d'accord
hier pour pour exprès cette idée il faut
briser la légitimité des autorités
concurrente à la république
déjà en scindant bien la sphère publique
et la sphère privée est également du
coup en affirmant fermement qu'il n'y a
qu'une seule source
deux décisions et c'est la république
elle ne souffre aucune concurrence et
donc ça ce serait important aussi de
revenir dessus
et enfin outre la question finalement de
la remise du peuple au centre de la
décision et l'a finalement le fait de ré
inventer de nouvelles formes de
référendum il faudra surtout réenchanter
notre démocratie quelque part et
replacer finalement le peuple au sens de
faim au centre de ce projet d'intérêt
général commun que nous devons
construire ensemble puisque et ses skis
revenue hier très fréquemment
nous devons retravailler la question de
l'universalité
nous ne sommes pas des citoyens
réductible à des catégories
nous ne sommes pas pour reprendre selon
98 black blanc beur femmes ou jeunes ou
vieux ou dans les ghettos nous sommes
tous citoyens français et donc il
faudrait réaffirmé cette universalité
cette unité du peuple français pour agir
ensemble et donc sous une seule bannière
c'est celle des citoyens français
voilà merci m la mari jean-daniel je
crois que vous allez aussi revenir sur
ces questions fondamentales et cette
distinction entre autorité et
autoritarisme
absolument bonjour à tous bonjour à tous
et sans s'être concertés jeu les mêmes
poursuivre une partie du propos qui
vient d'être acquis vienne est retenue
lorsque nous sommes amenés à travailler
auprès des françaises et des français
qu'on leur demande qu'est ce qu'être
français d'un point de vue général quel
rapport il peut avoir à la démocratie on
va très rapidement nous renvoyer déjà à
cette première période qu'elle appelle
de la révolution française et qui est un
moment qui est un moment terriblement
politiques et ou non seulement en fait
il y a eu l'avènement de la république
mais également la déclaration
universelle des droits de l'homme dans
un contexte qui est un contexte de
conflit tu as lite est extrêmement
marqué dans un contexte où l'histoire
s'écrivait à grands pas dans un
environnement où les conditions globales
du pays où la vue était relativement
instable la prétention des français a
été de se dire nous ne sommes pas que
français nous ne sommes pas qu'un
individu
nous avons également vocation à pouvoir
exprimer par delà le reste du monde
un certain nombre d'orientations un
certain nombre de valeurs un stand de
point où nous sommes collectivement
attachés et donc que ce rapport que l'on
peut voir aujourd'hui d'interrogation à
l'égard de l'autorité ce n'est pas
uniquement une interrogation autour de
l' autorité manifeste
certes il y à toutes les dimensions
d'incivilité dont vous avez parlé mais
également tout une question qui est une
question de légitimité de la part de
ceux qui sont aujourd'hui les vecteurs
les porteurs de cette autorité dans le
monde
il n'existe quasiment aucun pays qui est
aussi politique que la france
certes il y a des participations
électorales qui sont fluctuantes
certes il y à un niveau tendanciel de la
baisse de la participation
mais quand vous interrogez les français
et quand vous comparez les français aux
allemands aux britanniques
voire même aux américains le rapport au
politique n'est jamais le même il y a
toujours cette aspiration à faire en
sorte qu'il puisse y avoir dans le cas
de problème quel qu'il soit une réponse
qui soit une réponse à caractère
politique
c'est ce qui fait le bonheur de la
france mais ce qui fait faire parfois
également son malheur on le voit de
manière tendancielle que ce soit au
niveau national que soi même au niveau
local vous avez pris l'exemple tout à
l'heure des roms et des difficultés
auxquelles vous êtes confrontés les élus
locaux à pouvoir faire appliquer une
décision de bon sens où une
reconnaissance d'un dommage ou d'un
préjudice qui a peut être effectué nous
sommes systématiquement dans cette
situation là sommes nous face à des
responsables politiques qui ont les
moyens de leurs ambitions
sommes nous face à des responsables
politiques y ont la capacité à pouvoir
faire en sorte que cette notion de
justice
cette notion de responsabilité soient
respectées dans la société française
c'est avec souvent la perception que ce
soit sur des enjeux de sécurité que cela
soit des enjeux en matière de politique
publique que soient les enjeux en
matière de libertés en matière d'égalité
en matière de laïcité
la perception que nous sommes face à un
pouvoir politique qui l'a pas
toujours cette capacité à pouvoir mettre
en cohérence ses orientations ses
souhaits et la pratique politique qui
peut par la suite être amenés à en
découler ça a pu même se manifester ce
regard des français ambivalent à l'égard
de l'autorité
face à une tension qu'on a pu voir
récemment oui à l'auto était nous dit on
non à l'autoritarisme
oui à une décision qui est une décision
ferme
oui à une décision qui par la suite ne
conteste pas forcément de souffrance de
la part des uns et des autres mais pas
forcément une décision qui ne tiendrait
pas compte un minimum soit du mandat qui
a été confié à l'élu soit éventuellement
des réactions de la part des citoyens à
qui sont destinés les différentes
politiques publiques ce qui s'est passé
récemment à travers deux types de
comportements qui ont été radicalement
différent je crois sont instructifs le
premier aspect c'est la mobilisation des
gels et jaune mobilisation des gels et
jaune qui s'inscrit dans un contexte où
moins d'un électeur sur deux s'est
déplacé au premier tour des élections
législatives -2 43% des électeurs se
sont déplacés au deuxième tour des
élections législatives et avec des
gilets jaunes qui disent globalement
nous n'avons pas d'eau réceptacle à
notre colère nous n'avons pas
aujourd'hui d'acteurs qui sont
susceptibles de pouvoir dire ce que nous
vivons dans le cadre de notre quotidien
ce qui globalement nous préoccupe et
quelles peuvent être les solutions ni
globalement d'un point de vue politique
à travers la roche représentation
nationale ni à travers le politique à
l'elysée pas ce concept emmanuel macron
a été considéré comme étant le président
des riches et pas forcément le président
des catégories populaires
le président des villes et pas forcément
le président les campagnes et que dans
ce contexte là il y avait une difficulté
à pouvoir trouver une expression qui
l'expression à caractère politique pas
plus d'ailleurs d'expression ou de
revendication qui seraient prises en
compte par les organisations syndicales
ou par le tissu associatif
on l'a donc face une colère qui existe
souvent dans notre pays mais qui va
remettre en cause le principe même de
l'autorité de la puissance publique
notamment parce qu'il y a ni des mots
qui sont mis sur une situation vécue par
un certain nombre de noces
rien ni non plus la capacité à pouvoir
indiquer qu'il ya des perspectives qui
va être donnée à l'ordre son orientation
deuxième type d'exemple qu'on a pu voir
récemment les différentes conventions
notamment la convention citoyenne sur le
climat où on s'est dit à un moment qu'il
y as et l'écho qui a eu dans l'opinion
en est pour partie le reflet que nos
moyens traditionnels de représentation
de ce que pouvait être la puissance
publique
l'intérêt général échapper à nos
principes traditionnels de démocratie
représentative de prien de démocratie
par délégation dont deux exemples dans
des conditions de complicité qui ont été
extrêmement différente avec des
conditions faites d'expression qui là
aussi on était assez hétérogène mais qui
pour autant montre bien que dans notre
pays
l'autorité du pouvoir politique est
parfois remise en cause et trouve une
singularité d'un point de vue de python
peut-être pour finir et puis pour donner
un saint homme de perspectives ou
d'orientation dans ce pays politique
nous souffrons de l'absence de conflits
qualités politiques ou plus précisément
de conflits qualité sur les valeurs et
sur les idées et si on prend la table
ronde précédente sur le nucléaire sur le
rapport à l'écologie et à
l'environnement sur le rapport au social
sur le rapport aux transports sur le
rapport à l'achat sur le rapport à la
ruralité voire même sur le rapport
globalement à ce que peut être les sens
de la société française je suis pas
persuadé que ce qui a été dit sur cette
table ronde précédente aurait pu être
dit au tour d'autres tables rondes que
ce soit du côté de la gauche ou du côté
de la réplique en marche
c'est lorsqu'il ya une confrontation
politique importante c'est lorsqu'on
s'est dit qu'il y a des projets
politiques y sont différents c'est
lorsqu'on voit que les systèmes de
valeurs qui sont parfois antagonistes
que les français non seulement voient
une utilité à se déplacer pour aller
voter et après par la suite du fait de
la participation qui une participation
importante reconnaissent plus encore
l'autorité de l'état du fait justement
de la clarté du mandat initial et de la
puissance politique qui a été donné du
fait du comportement électoral des
français pour donner un mandat politique
aux responsables qui sont trop
responsabilité merci
beaucoup jean daniel dans ces éléments d
analyse pierre bruneau puissant fille
bien vous permettrez de saluer pour
commencer mon propos nos présidents mon
président du sénat le monde n'est pas
possessif il est simplement affectif je
suis heureux de me retrouver à ses côtés
notre président christian en le
remerciant de sa patience de sa
bienveillance pour des troupes parfois
qu'ils sont comment dirais-je un peu
libre dans leur expression merci mon
chat christian de ton invitation
remercier tous les habits françois
xavier qui dirige superbement bien notre
groupe à bruxelles bien sûr renaud
président de région eric un des grands
spécialistes de l'autorité de l'état du
régalien annie vice présidente michèle
agnès bien sûr un secrétaire
départemental du département ma chère
sophy merci à tous d'être ici et pour
rebondir sur les propos de jean daniel
lévy oui la démocratie a besoin de
conflits qualité la démocratie ça n'est
pas l'abolition des débats ça n'est pas
l'abolition des convictions et
j'aimerais en quelques mots vous dire
pourquoi quand j'ai eu 20 ans un âge que
beaucoup d'entre vous ont aujourd'hui le
discours politique qui m'a sans doute le
plus marqué a été le discours de camus
est comme lorsque lui a été remis le
prix nobel de littérature
vous connaissez sans doute tout cette
phrase cette très belle phrase qui est
une phrase qui a une résonance actuelle
aujourd'hui chaque génération se croit
voué à refaire le monde
votre tâche consiste à empêcher que le
monde se défasse et nous y sommes
aujourd'hui la question ça n'est pas le
monde encore moins le nouveau monde dont
nous espérons qu'ils se défera bientôt
la question aujourd'hui c'est la
question de la république derrière
l'autorité c'est la question de la
nation une nation française qui n'a
jamais été autant émietté jamais autant
archipel ise nous sommes entrés dans
l'âge des grandes séparation vous le
disiez il ya quelques instants e marie
la séparation des sexes
le néo féminisme à l'achat pas et à
d'autres qui est en train d'éclater le
concept d'unité d'humanité
entre deux camps irréductibles la
séparation entre les jeanne jeunes
contre vieux la séparation entre les
classes la deuxième partie de la
séquence des gilets jaunes la séparation
au cid entre les races avec un
antiracisme qui racialise les rapports
sociaux
bien oui ce que je veux vous dire ce
matin en m'adressant à chacun d'entre
vous c'est que votre tâche consistera à
ratisser ce qui était déchiré art
civilisé ceux qui étaient en sauvage et
en d'autres termes et pour le dire
autrement à reconstruire ce que les
générations précédentes et notamment la
génération 68 ap n'a cessé de
déconstruire la déconstruction de la
république une république défié par
l'affaissement d'autorité précisément
par l'ultra violence qui nuit aux plus
faibles d'entre nous une république
défier non pas seulement par le
séparatisme
osons le nommé par l'islamisme une
religion politisés qui se dressent
contre la république
les incidents de dijon plan ethnique
contre clans ethniques qui sont résolus
non pas la mairie ou à la préfecture
vous êtes assis mais à la mosquée est ce
que c'est ça la république la république
défier la démocratie aussi la démocratie
fragilisé quand un président de la
république nous proposent comme horizon
indépassable de la démocratie le tirage
au sort
la convention citoyenne une démocratie
du hasard une démocratie de la courte
paille la démocratie toujours quand ceux
d'en bas
quand ceux d'en bas ont le sentiment et
pas seulement sentiment que leur voix ne
compte plus aux deux sens du terme que
leurs voix ne compte plus parce que leur
opinion serait d opinion inconvenante
parce qu'ils pensent que l'immigration
massive n'est pas une chance parce
qu'ils pensent que l'insécurité n'est
pas seulement une question de sentiment
parce que l'insécurité eux
ils la vivent alors que ceux d'en haut
ils ne vivent pas parce qu'ils ont été
capables de financer dans leur quartier
de nouvelles frontières de nouveaux murs
et puis aussi de nation une nation
déchirée déchiré par l'ultra violence
déchirée par un communautarisme qui
trouve en face de lui qu'une pensée
molle une pensée molle parce que cette
pensée elle a été désarmé depuis des
années désarmé par ce que j'appelle la
célébration de la diversité du
multi-culturalisme qui nous empêche de
pencher aujourd'hui de penser le bien
commun un cadre commun alors ce que je
voudrais dire maintenant pour tenir des
propos plus politique et peut-être pour
que ces propos est une résonance au delà
même de cet hémicycle en s'adressant à
certains de nos amis mon cher christian
comment emmanuel macron pourrait-il
reconstruire la cohésion nationale
reconstruire l'état régalien alors que
c'était mal macro qui vient de libérer
ces derniers mois plus de 13 mille
détenus de nos prisons il n'a toujours
pas demandé à son garde des sceaux
d'abolir de rapporter la circulaire du
laxisme judiciaire qui date du 20 mai
dernier
rien n'a été fait comment monsieur
macron le recul me reconstruire la
cohésion nationale alors que candidat
souvenez vous il nous avait doctement
expliqué qu'il n'y avait pas de culture
française et que devenu président de la
république il avait mis à france au bord
des nations en accusant son pays notre
nation du pire des crimes qui puisse
exister
le crime contre l'humanité comment
emmanuel macron peut-il être cet homme
de la reconstruction républicaine de la
reconstruction nationale et je le dis à
nos amis évidemment je dis à ceux qui
ont perdu leur boussole de leur
conviction soit par opportunisme soit
par défaitiste ou bien parler d'eux
ce que je leur dis c'est kemmel macron
n'est en aucun cas le premier d'un
mouvement
c'est plutôt le dernier de l'ancien
monde
c'est en quelque sorte cette exécuteurs
testamentaires
il est le dernier né en réalité de cette
longue lignée de des constructeurs des
constructeurs de la république de la
nation dans l'idéologie par les idées
qui l'ont porté au pouvoir et votre
tâche parce que justement j'y viens pour
terminer votre lignée des pas celle de
la déconstruction
vous n'êtes pas vous ne serez jamais des
déconstructeurs de la cohésion nationale
vous êtes des bâtisseurs c'est votre
tâche votre tâche sera de reconstruire
de reconstruire cette cohésion nationale
qui est profondément déchiré de rebâtir
en quelque sorte un peuple un peuple
français attachés à nos valeurs
françaises
et pour cela il vous faudra redresser
deux piliers la république et la nation
d'abord la république avec la force de
la loi républicaine
il faudra bien évidemment relever l'état
l'état régalien avec une révolution
pénale avec un principe très simple on
pourra en discuter tout à l'heure un
délit un d'infraction une sanction une
sanction prononcer une sanction exécuté
vous vous rendez compte
un maire molesté ce mr molesté par celui
qui l'a volée c'est celui-là écopent de
quoi d'un rappel à la loi
évidemment qu'il faut abolir il faut
supprimer le rappel à la loi
la loi elle n'a pas être rappelé la loi
est là mes chers amis à être appliqué un
point c'est tout et il faudra comme
l'ont fait nos amis du pays bas
construire des prisons y compris pour
des courtes peines pour sanctionner
sanctionner très rapidement et c'est
fondamental et arrêté d'aménager les
peines
la jeune fille de ma région de nantes
qui était violée et assassinée par un
multirécidiviste il avait bénéficié
d'une rémission d'un réaménagement de
peine
eh bien je propose et nous proposons
qu'ils ne puissent plus y avoir ce type
de réaménage
deux peines quasiment automatique et il
faudra enfin une révolution une
révolution pour réformer la justice
je vous le dis parce que je sais que ça
n'est pas partagée par tous la justice
française n'a pas besoin de plus
indépendante elle l'est elle a besoin de
plus d'impartialité il faudra ouvrir les
fenêtres du recrutement de nos
magistrats
évidemment il faudra la responsabilité
comment est ce possible cher gérard
larcher c'est toi qui m'a appris ce
chiffre en trois ans le conseil
supérieur de la magistrature 1048
plainte sur ses 1048 plainte combien
sanctions entre 2015 et 2018
pas une seule et bien les magistrats
français ne doivent pas rendre la
justice au nom d'une idéologie comme on
l'a vu pour un petit nombre d'entre eux
avec le mur des cons ils doivent rendre
la justice
évidemment au nom du peuple français
c'est capital et redresser ce pilier
républicain la loi républicaine
ce sera aussi réaffirmé la laïcité
l'institut de l'institutionnalisation
d'un islam en france ça n'est pas le job
de l'état l'état n'a pas à dire quel est
le bon ou le mauvais islam la bonne ou
la mauvaise pratique
l'état doit garantir évidemment la
laïcité c'est à dire la citoyenneté
réaffirmer partout et toujours que la
loi civile
la loi républicaine est au dessus de la
loi religieuse
c'est une évidence et quand on regarde
[Applaudissements]
cher jean daniel lévy étude après étude
vous me voyez venir sondage après
sondage
et que vous voyez que nos compatriotes
musulmans parmi les plus jeunes un car
je crois refuse de condamner l'attentât
charlie-hebdo 74% je crois de moins de
25 ans pense que au dessus de la loi
républicaine
il y à la loi religieuse il faudra être
intraitable pour redresser la république
et il ya à rebâtir enfin la nation la
nation française
arrêtez de déboulonner les statues parce
que les déboulonneurs de statut
ça n'est pas l'éclairage de notre
histoire qu'il souhaite obtenir c'est la
criminalisation notre histoire c'est de
désigner de désigner vis-à-vis de ces
populations qui sont tentés par la
sécession de désigné la france comme un
éternel coupable notre destinée selon
eux ce devrait être la pénitence à
perpétuité la pénitence perpétuel et
bien nous aurons à réaffirmer la
conviction parce que s'il ya bien cette
conviction commune
mon cher christian chez les républicains
c'est l'amour de la france
non la france n'est pas à chagrin non la
france est pas abominable
non la france ne sont pas des crimes
contre l'humanité la france est une
espérance la france pour reprendre une
expression de marie sur l'universalité
la france c'est cette nation qui au
cours des âges au cours des siècles
génération en génération est parvenu à
accorder ce qu'il ya de plus universel
dans chaque homme dans chaque femme avec
de ce qu'il y à direct utile en
particulier dans chacun des hommes et
dans chacun des femmes alors soyons
fiers de la france faisant aimer la
france
ma conviction c'est que la droite comme
la france était à la croisée des chemins
aujourd'hui mais les ressorts de notre
développement futur
au delà de cette crise ça n'est pas les
100 milliards du plan de relance
le ressort de notre développement de
demain il est immatériel il faut renouer
avec l'idéal français avec un esprit de
conquête l'esprit français esprit de
conquête bien sûr économique sociale
écologique aussi vous ne pas tirer
rien serge ali jeune ou ne bâtit rien
sur les sables mouvants d'entre deux ou
alors de halle en même temps et vous
aurez tout à perdre si vous vous perdez
dans le marais des idées de mol ne
faites pas comme certains de vos aînés
ne vous résignez pas ne devenez pas
désabusé garder en vous cette énergie
vitale garder en vous ces valeurs
regarder en vo un enthousiasme une
espérance nous vous faisons confiance
nous comptons sur la force de vos
convictions et nous comptons sur vous
pour propager l'amour de la nation
française l'amour de la france merci
[Applaudissements]
bien merci merci à tous les trois pour
vos interventions pour ses propositions
ces éléments d'éclairage et ses éléments
aussi très stimulant chez pierre bruneau
donc je vais maintenant donner la parole
à la salle pour évidemment que vous
puissiez poser vos questions je serai
très exigeante sur le temps des
questions à ces deux minutes par
question qui sera posée
n'hésitez pas n'hésitez pas évidemment à
vous présenter et à rappeler de quelle
département vous venez donc soyez
rigoureux sur le temps de parole faute
de quoi je devrais faire preuve
d'autorité
alors qui veut commencer bonjour je
viens du maine-et-loire je suis étudiant
en droit et sciences politiques
ma question s'adresse à monsieur bruno
retailleau comment est-ce qu'on peut
renouer la confiance avec les français
en terme d'élus quand des décisions qui
sont prises par des élus légitimement
élus sont critiqués par des instances
qui n'ont une légitimité très relative
aux yeux des français je pense à la cour
européenne des droits de l'homme comment
est-ce que notre droit français
nationale il peut être remis en cause
par cette institution là sur le droit
des mineurs expulsé par exemple à
mayotte récemment sur le droit à la
violence légitime qui appartient à
l'état à l'usagé du lb des par exemple
été remis en cause par cette cour
européenne des droits de l'homme comment
est-ce que les français peuvent encore
croire à la politique quand ils ont
l'impression que la décision
le seul moyen décision qui est le vote
il l'aurait finalement parfois un peu
voler merci on va peut-être prendre
aussi une deuxième question
on va prendre une deuxième question il y
avait quelqu'un dit nous de tout vous
venez pour kombouaré cher du loir et
cher
merci alors pour les prisons bruno
retailleau
oui il faut sanctionner tout ça je suis
tout à fait d'accord mais il faut pas
oublier que pouvoir priver de liberté ça
implique aussi le devoir l'a restitué
guînes - concrètement que comptez vous
faire pour l'art et la réinsertion
deux questions très différentes
la première vous êtes dans le mille du
sujet notre problème nous sommes
parvenus nos démocraties parce que le
titre c'est la démocratie et l'autorité
de l'état et moi je vous ai beaucoup
parlé de cohésion nationale je pense
qu'aujourd'hui le problème dans les
démocraties occidentales qui sont
secoués par ce que l'on appelle des
mouvements il libéraux c'est que
beaucoup de peuples se demande qui
gouverne la question de la légitimité
abordé tout à l'heure par jean daniel
lévy est la question de qui gouverne
est ce que ce sont les gens qui votent
ou est ce que ce sont des instances
internationales ou des cours suprêmes y
compris en france qui doivent légiférer
parfois contre la volonté générale et en
europe
il ya beaucoup de peuples qui se
demandent si la démocratie n'est pas en
train de dériver
si cet état de droit que l'on vante tant
est un état où leur propre voix comme je
le disais ne compte plus pour dire
précisément et pour apprendre à votre
question je pense qu'on est parvenu un
moment où dans nos sociétés on donne
tout à des libertés individuelles très
individualiste au mépris au mépris du
cadre commun c'est à dire que si la loi
les tribunaux ne sont là que comme
greffier des caprices des revendications
individuelles
comment voulez vous essayer de faire une
société une communauté nationale avec un
cadre commun pousser cette rhétorique
des droits individuels poussé à
l'extrême est en train de déconstruire
notre cadre collectif
je le dis autrement et on l'a vu pour ce
que je récuse et que je ne veux pas
appeler et violences policières
il faudrait que la liberté individuelle
désormais garantissent les uns et les
autres y compris contre ce qu'on appelle
la violence légitime de l'état et
notamment sur la cod h je pense que nous
sommes tous prêts aujourd'hui de tomber
dans le gouvernement des juges
je pense pour ma part que la france
devrait réaffirmer un certain nombre de
réserves des réserves d'interprétation
parce que c'est la souveraineté comment
est ce que tu es juges internationaux
peuvent contredire la souveraineté
française la souveraineté nationale qui
n'est autre que la souveraineté
populaire du peuple français ses
institutions
aujourd'hui tourne malheureusement
parfois contre d'autres démocraties et
un équilibre fragile a trouvé entre la
garantie des droits individuels mais la
possibilité d'avoir un cadre commun et
aujourd'hui on est au bout du bout voilà
ce que je pense
et pour ce qui concerne la cee d âge moi
je me souviens le comité théodule des
droits de l'homme de l'onu avait
condamné la france sur la loi contre le
port de la burqa au titre au titre des
droits de la femme
alors que c'est un instrument qui
relètent au deuxième plan la flamme
voilà où nous en sommes
la france avait été condamnée par ce
comité théodule
voilà pour l'éclairage pour ce qui
concerne les prisons je faisais appel
parce qu'on dit souvent vous savez la
vitre la théorie de la vitre cassée new
york eric ciotti le connais bien c'est à
dire un délit au premier délit une
sanction il ya un autre pays sur lequel
on doit plus se pencher qui est plus
proche de chez nous qui est une grande
démocratie scandinave celle à olemps ce
sont les pays bas eux incarcère ont des
courtes peines
curieusement il emprisonne deux fois
plus mais rapportée à leur population
ils ont deux fois tu y es moins deux
détenus dans leurs prisons à tel point
je crois que la belgique avait loué
certaines de leurs prisons il ya un
livre qui s'est sorti je le recommande à
tous d'un médecin sur sept ce phénomène
de violence que dit ce médecin
il dit qu'il est absolument important
que la sanction est un sens et pour
qu'elle ait un sens il faut qu'elle soit
immédiate
donc je pense que quand on doit
construire des prisons on doit
construire aussi des centres pour des
courtes peines parce qu'on ne doit pas
mélanger des radicaliser terroristes on
voit ce que ça donne puisque un
chercheur pour le nommer hugo bicheron a
parlé des prisons comme l'ena de la
radicalité rendez compte
à tel point où on en est et dans
notamment ses centres de courtes peines
il faut impérativement amener les
détenus sur de la formation
professionnelle pour les préparer et moi
je vais vous dire je serais favorable à
ce que les détenus contribuer à leur
détention
financièrement comme je suis favorable à
ce que lorsque on donne une peine eric
l'avait proposé pour les allocations
familiales y ait des sanctions je ne
vois pas pourquoi des détenus qui
bénéficient les logements sociaux alors
que des français n'ont pas je ne vois
pas pourquoi il y aurait pas aussi une
sanction en arrêtant les aides sociales
parce que la nation française c'est
aussi la générosité mais en même temps
si j'ose dire
c'est encore bien entendu un certain
nombre de respect et le respect des lois
républicaines donc bien sûr à
l'insertion
merci bruno effectivement sur l'âme
la loi qui avait porté rick sur
l'absentéisme scolaire elle était elle
avait eu des effets et c'était et bien
s'il a été supprimée par la majorité de
françois hollande comme un certain
nombre de textes qu'ils ont été
détricoté par ce que il avait été adopté
par la majorité précédente et justement
par idéologie
alors on va prendre les questions
suivantes là haut
bonjour merci de me donner la parole
bonjour madame la députée monsieur le
sénateur je vous rejoins sur ce que vous
dites sur amsterdam j'étais moi-même
j'habitais à amsterdam avant d'être
rapatrié en france avant le juste avant
le confinement et c'est vrai que d'un
point de vue de l'autorité
ils sont je les trouve vraiment
excellents surtout comparé à nous quand
je suis revenu j'ai vite été ramené à la
réalité
- ce dont je voudrais vous parler ce
serait de la violence au niveau des
mineurs c'est à dire que je le vois tous
les jour où j'habite il ya une violence
des mineurs qui qui accroît
considérablement
donc je suis vraiment on va dire en
faveur de baisser
la majorité pénale ça je pense que c'est
une très bonne chose néanmoins je
voulais avoir votre point de vue sur la
responsabilité de la parentalité en fait
des parents dans
cette augmentation de 2 des violences
de la part des mineurs parce que moi je
peux pas concevoir que quand on est
parents qu'on laisse des enfants ne pas
aller à l'école par exemple qu'on laisse
des enfants en a 8 ans 10 ans 12 ans
jusqu'à des heures extrêmement tardive
dans des lieux critique où c'est
d'ailleurs là qu'il se font radicaliser
c'est d'ailleurs là qu'il se font
instrumentalisé par les délinquants
majeurs
donc j'aimerais avoir votre point de vue
sur la responsabilité des parents
est ce qu'il faudrait pas aussi les
faire comparaître ou du moins être ferme
vis-à-vis leurs responsabilités il y
avait une deuxième question je crois
juste derrière je voudrais ah bon je
vais faire une déclaration du millénaire
en m'adressant à monsieur otayo chaleur
parce que il est très lié ce qu'il a à
dire est tout à fait intéressant dans
tout la dit mais il je voudrais attirer
son attention sur le fait qu' il est il
faut pas ce serait un signe très
complexe d'opposer les libertés
individuelles haut du boîtier collective
parce qu'il est plus facile d'écraser un
individu qu'une collectivité
surtout lorsque on se sert des autorités
publiques
enfin ceux qui sont investis n'est ce
pas d'une parcelle de pouvoir s'en
prennent impunément et injustement à des
individus qui livrait à essence
et sans assistance plient sous la chape
n'est ce pas de plan eu des autorités il
n'est pas normal que s il n'est pas
normal que des autorités publiques
dispard élu démocratiquement prennent la
décision aux points de la décision de m
une personne un individu dans ce qu'on
appelle l'assignation à résidence à
partie des à partir si vous pouvez
conclure situation dans la situation
situation dans laquelle à partir de
laquelle on ne porte atteinte aux droits
fondamentaux 65 - de vos cours voilà
pourquoi je tenais beaucoup
alors j'ai aujourd'hui une troisième
alors allez-y y avait un jeune homme
encore là bas alors bonjour à tous
l'aîné je suis jeune jeunes républicains
j'aimerais public en des yvelines est
membre de l'ue n'ayez l'université de
paris alors je vous remercie beaucoup ne
va ordonner à la parole et je remercie
monsieur retailleau pour son bref
discours je me reconnais tout à fait
dans tout ce que vous avez dit aussi
dans le discours initial est aussi dans
vos réponses aux questions du public et
je voudrais peut-être aller un peu plus
loin et au rejet de l'antisémitisme est
demandée en fait on voit qu'en fait ils
avaient beaucoup des gens les
politiciens dont dans le pays qui
avaient des bonnes volontés pour lutter
contre l'antisémitisme
je pense notamment à nicolas sarkozy je
pense notamment à d'autres personnalités
de d'autres familles politiques ou
manuel valls et on va comme malgré les
bonnes volontés ça n'a pas réussi en
fait et moi je me demandais ce que
peut-être en fait pour réussir à
combattre
antisémitisme il faut en fait faire
quelque chose pour arrêter la
stigmatisation d'israël en fait facebook
ou des fois je pense que la stigmatisent
la stigmatisation d'israël celle qui
mène à l'antisémitisme je voulais savoir
hautement de vue monsieur retailleau
merci vous remercie on va commencer sur
la première question jean daniel lévy
sur la question de la minorité mais ça
sur le premier point en fait c'est ce
qu'on avait enfin nous identifient d'un
point de vue global d'un point de vue
d'opinion il a été indiqué tout à la
part par bruno retailleau où on aspire à
faire communauté nationale dans le pays
et c'est vrai que dès qu'il ya le
sentiment que soit on cède à des
communautés soient concert avec des
communautarismes soit concède à des
acteurs qui sont des acteurs qui ont
plus tendance à mettre en avant leurs
dimensions individuelles que leurs
regards qui est un regard collectif
tout ceci earth véritablement l'ensemble
de la population française en tout cas
une immense majorité de la population
française qui dit globalement on
souhaite se retrouver collectivement
ensemble et pas forcément être sûr
l'addition uniquement de regards qui va
être des regards individuelle et puis
sur l'autre aspect qui avait été évoqué
tout à l'heure la question fondamentale
c'est la question la responsabilité et
ce que disent les parents c'est nous
avons le sentiment d'être responsables
de nos enfants et nous avons le
sentiment que certains ne font pas
suffisamment d'efforts pour encadrer
leurs enfants voire même d'une manière
générale faire preuve d'autorité et on y
revient là dessus on revient là dessus
dans le cadre du processus qui est du
processus éducatif
or bien là dessus même d'une manière
générale dans le regard qui était plus
qui est affirmé à l'égard du de
l'éducation nationale
lorsqu'on interroge les parents
aujourd'hui leur première demande à
l'égard des enseignants
ce n'est pas uniquement la question la
transmission ce n'est pas uniquement la
question de l'apprentissage
la première de demande c'est une demande
de maintien de l'autorité dans la classe
donc les parents disent nous cherchons à
le faire nous mêmes nous demandons
également nous est si nous allons à
l'éducation nationale de le faire
également
et donc tous ceux qui donnent le
sentiment d'être un peu laxiste trop
laxiste avec leurs enfants sont
critiqués d'un point de vue d'opinion
merci bruno si tu voulais compléter très
il y avait trois questions je répond
brièvement à chacune d'entre elles pour
les mineures je suis d'accord
sur bien sûr la majorité l'âge de la
majorité je pense qu'il faut réformer
l'ordonnancé de 45
parce que aujourd'hui nous sommes au
21ème siècle et que les mineurs
d'aujourd'hui peuvent être des grands
gaillards et surtout la délinquance est
une délinquance extrêmement violente d
un âge extrêmement peu avancé donc je
vous rejoins je n'ajoute rien pour ce
qui concerne la liberté
je pense qu'un des marqueurs de la
droite mais depuis trois siècles
c'est l'amour de la liberté c'est la
liberté qui doit être une de nos
boussole donc ne me faites pas dire ce
que je n'ai pas dis simplement
simplement l'état à la deux a le devoir
de protéger les plus faibles
et permettez moi de vous dire gérard
larcher va à se boucher les oreilles que
la décision du conseil constitutionnel
qui a défait les mesures notamment pour
les condamnés pour des faits de
terrorisme ou associés à des entreprises
terroristes
nous voulions des mesures de sûreté
extrêmement bienveillante plutôt légère
et bien le conseil considère les a si
j'ose dire annulé il faut que la société
il faut que la société puisse se
protéger contre les plus violents les
plus en sauvage et il ya quelque chose
qui tourne pas rond dans la république
aujourd'hui il ya une inversion des
responsabilités des valeurs on désigne
les gendarmes et les policiers comme
coupables de violences alors que c'est
chaque jour qu'ils subissent l'ultra
violence on victimise les coupables et
en culpabiliser victimes quelque chose
ne tourner pas rond
donc je ne suis pas pour défaire la
liberté individuelle bien sûr mais je
pense que notre époque nous indique que
nous avons sur le curseur passé cet
équilibre ce point d' équilibre entre la
protection des libertés individuelles et
j'étais un de ceux au sénat qui a lutté
contre la loi avia contre la liberté
d'expression pour ne pas donner aux gars
femmes aux algorithmes ce pouvoir de
privatiser cette liberté d'expression je
sais de quoi je parle
je pense que le curseur est allé trop
loin et que on doit le ramener un point
d'équilibré
ça me paraît fondamental sur
l'antisémitisme vous savez qu'elle est
où est ce que voilà la meilleure réponse
à l'antisémitisme je n'en connais pas
d'autre c'est la république c'est tout
ce que j'ai dit c'est la lutte contre
l'islamisme et la lutte contre le
séparatisme c'est la lustres pour la
laïcité
et attention aujourd'hui à un gauchisme
qui est en train de retourner la cause
juste palestiniennes contre israël mais
aussi qui peut avancer
on l'a vu parfois lorsque par exemple
alain finkielkraut s'est fait traiter de
sale juif dans la rue donc on doit être
intraitable
intraitable sur ces questions la réponse
à l'antisémitisme c'est la république la
république française rien que la
république mais toute la république
vient nous allons prendre une nouvelle
série de questions monsieur bonjour
monsieur diallo mamadou bah sinon qu'est
élus de la seine saint denis
or les rennais d'adoption est élu la
scène ni depuis très peu dans la ville
des pavillons-sous-bois ch philippe
dallier donc chers sénateurs et
j'ai une question sur ta yo sur la
surpopulation carcérale notamment en
termes de dissuasion sur le crime en
france
souvent il ya une corrélation entre
surpopulation carcérale et le crime est
cité en célèbre un chercheur qui fait
mention de l'ena voilà entre guillemets
en milieu carcéral
moi je voudrais citer le modèle
américain où les peines laloum la
lourdeur des peines et la surpopulation
carcérale est un élément du siazim en
lien avec le crime en france
souvent on dit le milieu carcéral et et
surpeuplé
j'ai envie de dire plus et surpeuplé
plus peut-être un jour il y aurait des
faits pour du siav et le crime une
corrélation entre surpopulation
carcérale c'est pas en construisant plus
de prison que le crime va baisser au
contraire il ya un effet positif qui
dirait voilà plus on a des prises en
plus la prison serait assimilé un
système d'hôtel passagers pour tout type
de délit donc à mon sens il faudrait
plus de peine
une une lourdeur des peines mais aussi
ne pas se laisser aller
sur un phénomène d'hôtel lorsqu'on est
un milieu carcéral
la prison doit être avant tout une
sanction pas un hôtel s'il ya une autre
question bonjour taîwan salies 2 mrd vie
des hautes pyrénées
tout d'abord je n'ai pas ressenti autant
de passion depuis depuis nicolas sarkozy
dans un discours
donc merci à vous ma question elle va
être très simple j'aimerais avoir votre
avis sur le vote obligatoire qui sera
accompagné d'une comptabilisation du
vote blanc donc voilà allez une
troisième il y avait monsieur là
derrière
allez-y oui vous bonne jour blocage je
viens de toulouse
je voulais vous demander est-ce que vous
pensez que le porte d'armes en effet
positif net ou un effet négatif net sur
la société
merci merci bruno je commence par la
dernière j'ai essayé de vous communiquer
ma passion pour la france je ne vais pas
fait pour les états unis d'amérique
bien que bien que nous ayons un
cousinage par lafayette et aussi par la
tradition de liberté et de forme
d'universalité mais différente
donc non je ne recommande pas donc aux
autorités françaises je ne déposerait
pas avec eric ciotti une proposition de
loi pour généraliser le port d'armes
je pense que justement précisément si
nous ne voulons pas en venir
cette justice privée à des milices j'ai
lu pendant cet été la formation dans une
grande ville dans un département près
d'ici des gens tentés par des milices
privées non ça c'est la violence mais la
violence la revanche
et ça c'est le cycle de la haine mais
justement pour que ce cycle de la haine
soit interrompue c'est la justice c'est
la justice c'est à dire l'autorité et je
pense que c'est fondamental
j'avais une autre question alors sur les
prisons moi je suis en campagne
sénatoriale en vendée je suis stupéfait
c'est la première fois que jean je fais
chaque commune je suis stupéfait que
désormais en france dans des petites
communes rurales on me parle
d'insécurité
on a franchi un cap on a franchi un cap
en terme de quantité c'est à dire que
y'a plus seulement 9 3 qui peut être
concernés tous les départements y
compris les plus ruraux sont concernés
on a franchi un cap parce que c'est pas
seulement l'autorité qui est contesté
dans son exercice
elle est désormais contesté dans son
existence même
je pense comme vous regardez l'exemple
de la hollande est merci un des
intervenants tout à l'heure d'avoir
parlé d'un père d'âme parce que c'est un
exemple qui est peu connu il ya
désormais ils incarcèrent deux fois plus
il ya moitié moins deux détenus par
population dans les prisons simplement
ce que je peux vous dire c'est que ça
n'est pas en mettant les gens moins dans
les prisons j'ai fait allusion tout à
l'heure à cette circulaire qui est
incroyable de madame belloubet mais
madame taubira aurait pu la signer et
vous savez qu'il va y avoir un test très
intéressant en matière de sécurité est
ce que monsieur dupont moretti
est ce que monsieur dupont moretti valve
annulé cette circulaire c'est quoi c'est
une circulaire qui dit voilà avant un
mois pas de prison entre un mois et 6
ans et 6 mois y compris sur des
jugements qui ont déjà été prononcées en
remettant un principe important qui est
en france un principe juridique de la
chose jugée
donc on est assez d'accord simplement je
pense qu'il faut construire des prisons
pour que l'on puisse avoir sur les 80 70
ou 80 mille peines qui ne sont pas
exécutées la place parce qu'aujourd'hui
je vais vous dire pour résumer vous
allez tout comprendre quelle est la
politique pénale de la france est bien
la politique pénale de la france c'est
simplement le numerus clausus en prison
un point final on a enlevé le numerus
clausus pour les études de médecine on
l'a remis pour la politique pénale de la
france est désormais dans les tribunaux
de grande instance
on appelle la prison est ce que vous
avez de la place et on ajuste la peine
prononcée
la peine prononcée même pas la peine
exécutée à la place disponible en prison
ça je suis désolé ça n'est pas
l'autorité républicaine que j'appelle de
mes voeux
[Applaudissements]
pardon vote blanc votre ligue at war
alors il ya comme sénateur je pourrais
être pour le vote obligatoire puisque en
france je vous l'apprends marie vous le
savez la seule élection où le vote est
obligatoire il est punie de 100 euros
damende c'est le vote sénatorial parce
qu'on considère que sont des grands
électeurs donc ils doivent être présents
et il ya un petit corps électoral donc
voilà non moi je
franchement je suis attaché à la liberté
je pense que la clé le questionnement
sur la question de la légitimité et sur
la démocratie on doit y recourait
autrement moi je suis favorable à
utiliser beaucoup plus largement le
référendum pas le référendum
d'initiative partagée sur ce que l'on
vient d'appeler les animalistes et
antispécistes je pense que il faut
recourir beaucoup plus il faut donner la
parole au peuple
voilà j'ai été un de ceux qui n'a pas
voté le traité de lisbonne sur l'europe
parce que je considérais que le peuple
français par référendum avait dit non au
traité constitutionnel et par conséquent
je me considérais comme est légitime au
parlement à revenir sur l'expression
général la volonté générale du peuple de
france parce que je dis merci on va
prendre la dernière série de questions
il n'y a pas de femmes non plus qui pose
de questions sur ce sujet 6 alors
monsieur là haut
alors bonjour thébert logan donc je suis
jeune républicain de 0,4 et je suis
aligné à la fac de droit ex ma question
concerne en fait la laïcité
je voulais savoir comment pouvons-nous
faire quant à la gestion des écoles hors
contrats d'état qui sont en fin de
compte des écoles d'islamisation parce
que ces écoles la forme par le biais de
la socialisation primaire les futurs
jihadistes et islamise les banlieues
aujourd'hui père c'est une autre
question là bas monsieur est alors une
jeune femme devant
allez-y présentez vous désole une
deuxième question du coup je me
représente l'algérie je suis étudiante
en affaires publiques plus veinards
j'avais deux questions pour vous qui
sont très liés la première c'est sûr
mouvement qu'on a très récemment vu
black line matters qui s'est trop
transcrit en france pour moi c'est
impossible aujourd'hui de voir que
l'état réagit moins aux manifestations
de ce type dans lesquels justement la
question de l'antisémitisme a été posée
ou des sales juifs aient été proférées
ou un dédain manifeste envers l'autorité
de l'état était fièrement proclamé
quelle est selon vous la réaction
typique que un gouvernement à droite
doit avoir face à ce type de
manifestation borderline et la seconde
question c'était sûr vous avez parlé de
l'ordonance de madame b loubet est-ce
que selon vous c'est très simple est ce
qu'il serait possible de revenir dessus
et de refaire venir en prison les
affiliés de jadis qui ont été libérés
pendant confinement mois la version est
encore une troisième question il y avait
un monsieur avec une veste marron
allez-y
bonjour julien à base de toulouse encore
je voudrais parler de la démocratie
autorités de l'état sous le également de
liberté d'expression sous le prisme des
réseaux sociaux alors sur ce sujet là on
a pu voir donc
on sait très bien tout ce que les
réseaux sociaux peuvent être un endroit
très intéressant et riche pour le débat
mais parce qu'il ya un mais c'est aussi
un vivier de défiance de l'autorité de
l'état
alors ma question sans tomber
effectivement dans la loi avia qui
déléguait aux gaffes a effectivement le
la responsabilité de gestion un peu des
réseaux sociaux
faut-il encadrer les réseaux sociaux si
oui comment bien merci bruno si tu peux
répondre en étant très concis parce que
nous reste très peu de temps sur les
écoles annie genevard aurait pu répondre
comme moi nous avons voté il ya quelques
mois un texte d'origine sénatoriale
justement pour faire en sorte de donner
au maire et à la puissance publique des
outils y compris pour contrôler
l'ouverture de ces écoles pour contrôler
ce qui s'y enseignes et pour pouvoir
mettre fin précisément des écoles
radicaliser notamment coranique je vous
rejoins totalement
c'est un phénomène qui s'étend on a plus
de 100000 désormais je crois jeunes qui
suivent ces écoles attention des écoles
hors contrats privés peuvent être
d'excellents lieu de formation il ya
beaucoup d'écoles montessori ton que
dans ces cas là il faut être très
attentif à ce que on vise la bonne cible
et pas le reste
deuxième chose plus sur blacklight
matters est belle aime pas bruno le
maire mais black like the matters non
voilà et moi je ça a été extraordinaire
c'est une violence qui nous vient des
états unis a eu la sphère traoré voilà
et on a laissé croire aux français que
la police française que la gendarmerie
française que le peuple français
on était tous racistes et bien il faut
résister jamais vous m'entendez
je ne mettrai un genou à terre et
souvenez-vous c'est emmanuel macron qui
avait demandé à son ministre de
l'intérieur de l'époque
voilà deux d'aller faire à la télévision
une conférence de presse qui avait été
incroyable incroyable pour dire
simplement que désormais en france
l'émotion devait prévaloir par rapport à
la règle savent mais cher c'est là des
civilisation la civilisation n'est dès
lors que l'on parvient à régler des
différends
non pas par la violence par l'émotion
mais au contraire par des règles
communes des règles communes que l'on
s'impose ça me paraît évident donc voilà
la réponse de la droite doit ce que on
n'a cessé de dire à l'assemblée comme au
sénat dans nos groupes respectifs
attention la circulaire du 20 mai n'a
rien à voir avec le ce que je vous ai
dit sur la libération des 150 d'ici 2022
djihadistes ou plutôt assimilés aux
djihadistes 1 c'est le problème de la
prison en réalité ces mots nomme madame
taubira sors de ce corps
madame taubira sort du corps sortez du
corps aussi de monsieur dupont moretti
c'est la même chose
vous allez vous en apercevoir relisez
une dépêche qui parut avec les propos de
monsieur dupont moretti
cette semaine vous avez la carte
alors il est sympathique parce qu'ils
chassent figurez-vous au vol et ceara il
a eu des propos par le passé
terriblement sympathique c'est une
grande gueule vu à la télé très bien
mais quand vous voyez ces déclarations
communiste vous avez la carte d'identité
d'une forme de gauchisme judiciaire
voilà donc moi j'attends autre chose
[Applaudissements]
je vais vous décevoir mais c'est parce
que je suis j'ai lutté contre la loi via
pied à pied parce que je considérais
qu'on ne pouvait pas remettre la liberté
d'expression qui est le coeur de la
démocratie française à des algorithmes
contrôlés par des gaffes un jeu penser
j'en suis victime moi comme d'autres de
la violence sur les réseaux sociaux
je pense et j'ai passé dix années de ma
vie à étudier l numérique
je pense qu'il vaut mieux laisser des
angles morts
laisser la liberté internet n'est pas
une zone de non droit vous avez le juge
peut prononcer un certain nombre de
sanctions
mais évidemment c'est difficile entre le
risque de dérapage précisément
autoritaire et cette liberté
d'expression parce que malheureusement
les réseaux sociaux sont souvent le
grand déversoir des humeurs je préfère
le second risque au premier risque et
c'est très difficile
je vous le dis tu es très très difficile
de réguler efficacement les réseaux
sociaux mais ça si la démocratie dans la
démocratie
que ce soit sur les réseaux sociaux que
ce soit sur les médias traditionnels
dans une réunion publique eh bien il ya
une forme de liberté d'expression on
n'est pas d'accord peu importe quand ça
dérape il ya le juge mais je pense que
soyons attaché d'abord au principe de
liberté contrôler et réguler par le juge
mais faisons attention aux dérives de
l'autoritarisme
moi je veux l'autorité de l'état mais je
ne veux pas et pour conclure
l'autoritarisme qu'a pu percer parfois
dans les propos des mails macron on
parlait tout à l'heure de verticalité
moi ce que je conteste puisque il s'est
fait élire avec une forme de verticalité
souvenez vous la marche du la marche
martial le soir du louvre la verticalité
la verticalité de monsieur macron était
une fausse verticalité la verticalité
régaliennes c'est le plus fort qui doit
aux plus faibles
la protection la verticalité bakr onion
c'est une verticalité qui est un
narcissisme qu'il retourne pour lui même
pour ce magnifique et vous avez là une
des explications de son incapacité à
faire respecter l'autorité de l'état une
vraie verticalité régaliennes qui ne
soit autre chose que le souci du plus
faible dans notre société ultra violente
merci bien merci beaucoup à tous les
trois merci jean daniel merci marie
merci bruno pour la qualité de cet
échange avec la salle
nous allons donc suspendre ces débats
pour la pause déjeuner nous retrouverons
à 14h30 avec aurélien pradié bon
déjeuner bon appétit à tous merci